NCAA TOURNAMENT SO FAR THEN
ROBERTS AND THE GOLDEN EAGLES
HEAD COACH PAUL MILLS JOINING
THE RICH EYES AND SHOW RIGHT
NOW COACH DAN HALEY HERE. SO
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON I CANNOT
TELL YOU HOW CRAZY IT WAS TO
SEE YOU GUYS. DO WHAT YOU DID
TO GET TO THE SWEET 16 JUST
THE SECOND 15 SEED EVER TO
MAKE IT THIS FAR IN THE
TOURNAMENT AND APPARENTLY
IT'S NOT A BIG SURPRISE TO
YOU BEEN TELLING YOU GUYS ALL
SEASON LONG. YOU'RE GONNA DO
THIS RIGHT? WELL, DAN.
N1 THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
TO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW ANY
TIME THAT YOU'RE COMPETITIVE
AND YOU BELIEVE IN THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE TRYING TO HOPE THAT
MENTALITY AND INSTILL THAT
CONFIDENCE AND NOT PHONY
CONFIDENCE, BUT I BELIEVE
THAT OUR PLAYERS HAD PUT IN
THE WORK, I BELIEVE THAT THAT
WE WERE COMPETITIVE. I MEAN
IF YOU GO LOOK WE PLAYED THE
THIRD TOUGHEST NON-CONFERENCE.
THE ONE THAT COUNTRIES ALL
FIVE TEAMS THAT WE PLAYED IN
THE NON-CONFERENCE MADE THE
NCAA TOURNAMENT THAT WE
DIDN'T WIN ANY OF THOSE GAMES
LOST BY FIVE TO OKLAHOMA
STATE AT OSU LOST BY FIVE AT
WICHITA STATE. WE WERE UP 12
ON ARKANSAS IN THE SECOND
HALF ENDED UP LOSING THAT ONE
AND SO WE KNEW THAT IF WE
TIGHTENED UP SOME AREAS ON
SOME REALLY GOOD TEAMS THAT
THESE ARE TWO POSSESSIONS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE UP AND I
OF COURSE OF THE YEAR THAT WE
WOULD MAKE THOSE CORRECTIONS
AND TO OUR GUYS CREDIT WE'VE
DONE THAT. YEAH, I WOULD SAY
SO I'M JUST LOOKING AT YOUR
YOUR TWITTER PAGE RIGHT NOW
COACH MILLS AND I THINK THIS
SWEET 16 RUN DESERVES
VERIFICATION. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONTACT WITTER GET
THAT BLUE CHECKMARK FOR YOU.
I'M SURE THAT WILL BE COMING
DOWN THE PIPE AT ANY MOMENT
RIGHT HAS TO I'M NOT YEAH, I
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT
VERIFICATION. I HAVE TWO
TEENAGE DAUGHTERS AND WHEN I
TOOK THE JOB HERE
HERE THEY SAID YOUR JOBS TO
GET VERIFIED OR YOU AND
AND AND SO I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANT. BUT HONEST
TO GOODNESS. IT'S RIGHT. I
DON'T CARE ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WELL, IT'S FUNNY. YOU SAID
ABOUT THE THE TEENAGE
DAUGHTERS. I HAVE A TEENAGE
SON AND DAUGHTER 13 AND 14.
AND YEAH, THEY GET THEY GET
QUITE A KICK OUT OF THAT.
THEY'RE LIKE DAD THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE. I DON'T THAT
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
TEACH KIDS. WHAT IS THAT
WATCH?
THIS RUN FOR YOU GUYS. WELL,
IT'S GREAT. I MEAN MY KIDS
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ALL IN ON
WHEREVER WE WERE THEY DO HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF SHRILLS
WHEN OTHER PEOPLE SHOOT FREE
THROWS SO THEY CAN CHANGE
OCTAVE LEVELS BASED UPON
YOUR FREE THROW PERCENTAGE.
IF YOU'RE BAD, THEY'LL GO A
LITTLE LOWER IF YOU'RE REALLY
GOOD THOSE DRILLS WILL GET
REALLY HIGHER SO THEY'VE BEEN
ALL IN WHAT'S BEEN TOUGH IS
YOU CAN'T EVEN TOUCH HIM
RIGHT? YOU CAN'T EVEN HUG
YOUR WIFE.
HEY, IF YOU CAN'T HUG YOUR
CHILDREN AFTER MOMENTS LIKE
OHIO STATE AND AND FLORIDA
LAST NIGHT. SO FROM THAT
CONTEXT, IT'S JUST YOU GOT TO
WAIT TILL THEM. SO THEY'RE
OLD ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND THAT
I FEEL BAD FOR SOME OF OUR
OTHER COACHES WHO HAVE YOU
KNOW, FOUR YEAR OLDS AND
TWO-YEAR-OLDS AND AND THEY
WANT DAD TO LOSE FOR SOME OF
OUR ASSISTANT COACHES. DO
THEY WANT TO SEE HIM AND GET
HIM BACK HOME, BUT THAT THAT
THAT'S BEEN TOUGH.
OBVIOUSLY NOT BEING ABLE TO
SHARE THOSE MOMENTS WITH YOUR
FAMILY. HOW DO YOU KEEP YOUR
GUYS FROM FROM GETTING TOO
HIGH? I MEAN YOU WIN THAT
THAT FIRST ROUND GAME AGAINST
SECOND SEAT AT OHIO STATE
AND THEN YOU COME BACK
AGAINST FLORIDA FROM YOU KNOW,
AN 11 POINT DEFICIT IN THE
SECOND HALF. WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT THESE TROOPS THAT YOU
JUST HAVE THEM BELIEVING?
WELL ONE IF YOU GET TOO HIGH
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE AND SO
IF YOU LIKE LOSING GO AHEAD
AND
BOTH PAY ATTENTION TO ALL THE
HEIGHT READ THE SOCIAL MEDIA
AND RETURN ALL THE TEXT
MESSAGES IF YOU DON'T LIKE
LOSING THEN GET FOCUSED IN
ON WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND THERE
THERE WILL BE A TIME TO
RETURN ALL THESE TEXT
MESSAGES DEAL WITH ALL OF
THESE OTHER ISSUES. WE'RE OFF
ACTUALLY TODAY AND WE'LL BE
OFF TOMORROW IN ORDER TO HAVE
THESE GUYS REST BECAUSE WE
DON'T PLAY UNTIL SATURDAY
EVENING, BUT I MEAN YOU GET
YOU HAVE TO TURN THE PAGE
I MEAN I HEARD A OLD FOOTBALL
COACH THEY WERE IN TIME
EUROPE PEACOCK ONE DAY AND
THEN YOU'RE A FEATHER DUSTER
TOMORROW AND YOU REALIZE JUST
ONE HOW QUICKLY THIS THING
CAN CHANGE IF YOU DON'T LOCK
IN ON YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES,
HAVE A VERY MATURE GROUP AND
AT YOUR A PEACOCK ONE DAY AND
A FEATHER DUSTER THE NEXT MAN.
I LIKE THAT THAT IS THAT IS
PENTHOUSE TO THE OUTHOUSE IN
A HURRY DAN HALEY ON THE RICH
EISEN SHOW FILLING IN WITH
PAUL MILLS THE HEAD COACH AT
ORAL ROBERTS. IT IS THE
CINDERELLA STORY OF THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT THIS YEAR. WHAT AN
AMAZING RUN IT HAS BEEN FOR
THE GOLDEN EAGLES. THEY BEAT
OHIO STATE THEN THEY BEAT
FLORIDA JUST A SECOND 15 SEED
TO EVER MAKE IT TO THE SWEET
16 IN THE FLORIDA GAME. YOU
GUYS HAD THAT INTENTIONAL
THEY'RE ABOUT THREE MINUTES
TO GO KIND OF A RISKY MOVE
. THE ANALYTICS SAID THAT IT
WAS A SMART MOVE WAS THAT WAS
THAT YOUR IDEA YOU GUYS WERE
DOWN ONE. I BELIEVE AT THAT
POINT. WAS THAT YOUR IDEA OR
DO WE NEED TO GIVE
TO IT TO A REALLY SMART
ASSISTANT FOR THAT ONE. YEAH,
ACTUALLY OUR GRADUATE
ASSISTANT IN LAYMAN AND IAN
WAS META INDIANA AND HE AND
SAM PATTERSON WOULD HAVE MY
ASSISTANT COACHES SAID HEY 15
IS 6 FOR 12 AND I LOOKED OVER
AND I SAID IN THE SEC OR ON
THE YEAR AND THEY SAID ON THE
YEAR AND I SAID WE'RE
FOLLOWING HIM AND SO CREDIT
TO TO IAN LEHMAN AND COACH
PATTERSON AND FOR BRINGING
THAT UP, BUT WE WERE
AT THE FREE-THROW LINE
SHOOTING MAX WAS TO CUT A
THREE-POINT DEFICIT TO ONE
AND WE WEREN'T ABLE TO GET
STOPS. AND SO WE KNEW A PLAY
CALLED THAT THEY WERE ABOUT
TO RUN AND WE KNEW THAT THAT
THAT GUY WAS GOING TO TOUCH
IT AND FORTUNATELY IT WORKED
OUT FOR US. SO EXPLAIN
TO ME THE SITUATION WITH
WITH DANCING ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE I'M ASSUMING SOME
PEOPLE ARE DANCING A LITTLE
BIT LATELY THE WAY THINGS
HAVE BEEN GOING FOR YOU. YEAH.
HONESTLY DON'T KNOW II MEAN I
DOUBT THERE AND I'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY THERE'S A
PROHIBITION AGAINST DANCING.
THE PRESIDENT ASKED ME TO
DANCE AFTER WE WENT TO THE
CONFERENCE TOURNAMENT. SO
SURELY THAT'S NOT A POLICY.
THE PRESIDENT IS ENCOURAGING
IT, BUT II DO LIKE THE WHOLE
IDEA IS NOT AS IF YOU COULD
EVER STOP KIDS FROM DANCING.
I DON'T EVEN THINK THAT'S
POSSIBLE. I KNOW BAYLOR WHEN
I WAS THERE. I THINK THEY HAD
A POLICY WAY BACK IN THE
SURE AT SOME POINT NUMBER OF
CHRISTIAN UNIVERSITIES MAY
HAVE HAD CERTAIN THINGS IN
PLACE THAT THAT THEY REALIZE
NOW MAY NOT BE THE CASE THAT
THAT YOU CAN KIND OF PUT
LIMITS ON PEOPLE, BUT IT WAS
GLAD TO SEEING READ A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN THE MAYBE CENTER
WHERE WE PLAY AND IT WASN'T
SOCIALLY DISTANCED, BUT BUT
IT'S GOOD TO SEE KIND OF
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR MIND FOR A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR.
EVERYBODY IS
UNDER BEST TO STAY AWAY AND
AND TO HAVE AN EVENT THAT
COULD JUST KIND OF BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER FOR EVEN JUST
A BRIEF MOMENT IS PRETTY COOL.
YOU'LL THEN HELI FILLING IN
ON THE RICH EYES AND SHOW
TALKING TO PAUL MILLS HEAD
COACH OF ORAL ROBERTS. IT IS
BY FAR, YOU KNOW THE BEST
STORY OF THE NCAA TOURNAMENT
SO FAR AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
GREAT ONES OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW COACH YOU TALKED ABOUT
KEEPING THE KIDS OFF SOCIAL
MEDIA. WE DON'T NEED TO
ANSWER ALL THE TEXT MESSAGES.
IS THAT EVEN POSSIBLE? AND IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU REALLY SAY
TO ME? HEY, LET'S JUST PUT
THE PHONES DOWN FOR A WHILE
ONE. IT IS POSSIBLE. I MEAN
IT ISN'T AS IF YOU CAN'T DO
IT.
TO THE THERE'S A TIME AND A
PLACE FOR IT. RIGHT? I MEAN I
AS I TOLD THEM TALK TO YOUR
MOM TALKED TO YOUR DAD TALK
TO YOUR GIRLFRIEND, BUT I MEAN
NOBODY'S GOING TO THINK
YOU'RE RUDE BECAUSE YOU'RE
FOCUSED IN ON YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES, AND AND I
DO THINK THAT PROBABLY YOU'RE
MORE MATURE PLAYERS KNOW HOW
TO HANDLE THAT KIND OF THING
AND AND MAYBE SOME YOUNGER
GUYS DON'T BUT II
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THAT
WHAT OUR GUYS ENJOY IS
WINNING AND BEING TOGETHER
AND IN ORDER FOR THOSE THINGS
TO HAPPEN YOU DO I HAVE TO
AVOID DISTRACTIONS YOU TALK
ABOUT SOME OF YOUR LEADERS
MAX A SMITH'S AND KEVIN. OH
BANNER HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTE
STALLIONS FOR YOU IN THIS
TOURNAMENT. I DON'T KNOW THAT
I'VE SEEN TWO GUYS HAVE
BACK-TO-BACK GAMES AS GOOD AS
THEY'VE HAD IN A LONG TIME.
HOW MUCH DO YOU LEAN ON THESE
TWO? WELL, THEY'RE THE BEST
DUO IN THE COUNTRY SCORING
WISE MAN.
IS OBVIOUSLY THE LEADING
SCORER IN THE COUNTRY AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT KEVIN AND
HIS CONTRIBUTIONS, THERE'S NO
OTHER TEAM WHO AS A DUO LIKE
WE DO AND AND PEOPLE KNOW
THAT RIGHT AND SO
IT'S ONE THING TO PERFORM
WHEN YOU'RE NOT A FOCUS OF
THE DEFENSE HAS A DIFFERENT
ELEMENT TO DO.
WHEN YOU ARE, BUT THEY'RE
ALSO THE TWO BEST IN THE
COUNTRY IN MY MIND DID MIDDLE
PICK AND ROLL AND SO WE PUT
THOSE GUYS IN A TON OF
DIFFERENT MIDDLE PICK AND
IN A TON OF DIFFERENT MIDDLE
PICK AND ROLL SITUATIONS AND
MAX IS MAKING THE RIGHT READ.
KEVIN IS MAKING THE RIGHT
READ AND AND THEY'RE DOING A
PHENOMENAL JOB OF JUST THIS
IS ACTUALLY THE BEST PLATE WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT WE'RE NOT
HERE TO GET A GOOD SHOT.
WE'RE HERE TO GET A GREAT
SHOT AND AND THEY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR STRENGTHS ARE AND
TERRIFIC WORK AND MIDDLE PICK
AND ROLL, ESPECIALLY WITH ALL
OF THE COVERAGES THAT WE'VE
SEEN THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR BECAUSE AND WE'VE
SEEN IT ALL FROM TRAPPIN TO
SWITCHING REGARDLESS OF
WHAT IT IS. WE'VE KIND OF
SEEN ALL THE ELEMENTS AND
THEY'VE HANDLED ALL THIS
STUFF REALLY. WELL, THEY'VE
BEEN FANTASTIC. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING FOR? THE NEXT COUPLE OF
DAYS OBVIOUSLY YOUR PREP
YOU'RE PRACTICING YOU'RE
HANGING OUT BUT DURING THE
DAY WHEN YOU'RE NOT ON THE
PRACTICE FLOOR. WHAT ARE YOU
GUYS DOING IS A TEAM HOW
TIME DO THESE PLAYERS GET ON
BECAUSE THERE'S YOU'RE NOT
GOING ANYWHERE. YEAH. YEAH,
WE HAVEN'T BREATHED ANY
INDIANAPOLIS. ARE YOU JUST
BRINGS AN AIR CONDITIONING
THE WHOLE TIME? SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO GET A
KICKBALL GAME IN THE BASEBALL
FIELD THAT THEY'RE ALLOWING
US TO GET ACROSS SO I GOT TO
MAKE SURE I STRETCH I DON'T
WANT TO PULL A HAMSTRING YOUR
ANYTHING. YOU'RE GOING TO
PLAY IN THE GAME. OH, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY. WE'LL
PROBABLY DO STAFF VERSUS
A HUNDRED GRADUATE ASSISTANTS
AND STUDENT MANAGER SO WE CAN
OUTNUMBER THEM BY QUITE A BIT
AND MAKE SURE EVERYBODY'S IN
THE FIELD WILL LOSE IT
ATHLETICALLY, BUT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO BREATHE FRESH AIR
RIGHT NOW. AND THE REALITY IS
IS OUR GUYS HAVE SCHOOL WORK
TO DO AND THEY'VE GOT A
RESPONSIBILITY THERE. AND SO
THEY'VE GOT TUTORING VIA ZOOM.
THEY'VE GOT CLASSES VIA ZOOM
AND AND SO THEY HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
STUDENT AS WELL AND THEN YOUR
TESTING EVERY DAY. OH YOU'RE
WATCHING FILM. AND SO WE WE
KEEP THEM BUSY. WE DON'T LET
HIM JUST GET TO THEIR OWN
RIGHT THERE IS ABOUT A
TWO-HOUR PERIOD WHERE THEY'RE
PLAYING A NUMBER OF CARD
GAMES AND INTO K ON PS5
. SO THERE IS A BREAK
BROUGHT UP SCHOOL. I ALMOST
FORGOT THAT THEY HAD TO TAKE
CLASSES. I CAN GET OUT
TOURNAMENT FINAL. YES. YEAH,
THAT'S WILD. SO YOU GUYS HAVE
YOU HAVE ARKANSAS COMING UP
NEXT YOU PLAYED THEM BEFORE
RIGHT IN DECEMBER PLAY THEM
IN DECEMBER AND AND THEY A
SMITH HAD AN UNCHARACTERISTIC
GAME FOR HIM. JUST 11 POINTS.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM
PLAYING THE RAZORBACKS IN
THAT GAME ONE WORD DIFFERENT
TEAM THAN WHAT WE WERE WE
AT THE HALF OR WE WERE UP 10
AT THE HALF GOT UP 12 EARLY
AND AND THEN THEY BASICALLY
TURNED UP THEIR OFFENSIVE
REBOUNDING TRANSITION GAME
AND WE DIDN'T DO WELL THE ONE
THING THAT DID HAPPEN THAT
GAME WAS MAX MAX WE WOULD
KIND OF ONE OF OUR OTHER
PLAYERS WE WOULD KIND OF MOVE
THEM BOTH ON THE BALL AND OFF
THE BALL. WHEREAS WE'RE WAY
DIFFERENT NOW THAN WHAT WERE
YOU WEREN'T IN SIMPLY BECAUSE
AND ABOUT 99.99% OF THE TIME
NOW AND SO AND SO FROM THAT I
JUST THINK THE
DECISION-MAKING SINCE THAT
COURSE OF THE GAME WE BECOME
A DIFFERENT TEAM AND IT'S
OBVIOUSLY PLAYED OUT REALLY
WELL FOR US. I'M LOOKING AT
YOUR SCHEDULE HERE AND YOU HAD
YOU KNOW, WHAT ONE TWO,
THREE THREE GAMES CANCELED A
COUPLE POSTPONED. WE HAD ONE
AGAINST WE HAD ONE CONFERENCE
ROOMS THAT WAS SCHEDULED
AND THEN WE HAD
ONE OTHER NON CONFERENCE GAME
THAT GOT DELAYED FOR A WEEK.
SO WE LITERALLY ONLY HAD ONE
GAME THAT WE HAD TO MISS ALL
YEAR ON ACCOUNT OF CODED. SO
YOU PLAYED NEARLY A FULL
IS NOT THE CASE FOR A LOT OF
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH
COAL WITH THIS YEAR OUR TEAM.
SO WE'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE
THAT THAT IS THAT'S
OUTSTANDING AND I GUESS
YOU'RE VERY FORTUNATE NOW TOO
BECAUSE WHEN YOU PUNCH YOUR
NAME INTO GOOGLE ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS THAT POPS UP IS
YOUR QUOTE ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO DO LAUNDRY NOW,
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU GOT TO
HAVE DONE THE LAUNDRY YET?
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY CAME BY
SO WE GOT BACK. I DON'T KNOW
MIDNIGHT LAST NIGHT AND ABOUT
ONE O'CLOCK. THEY GAVE US A
EGG AND THEN THEY SAID HEY,
IT HAS TO BE OUT AT 9:00 AND
BUY ONE. I HAD TWO BAGS FULL
AND WAS SITTING OUTSIDE MY
DOOR AND SOMEBODY WAS KIND
ENOUGH TO COME GRAB IT. THEY
CAME BY LAST NIGHT AND JUST
GRABBED OUR LAUNDRY. SO I
THINK THEY SAID IT'D BE READY
AT SOMETIME AROUND 2:00
O'CLOCK TODAY. AND AND THAT
IS A GOOD THING BECAUSE
LITERALLY OUT OF CLOTHES.
WELL, YOU GOTTA BE CAREFUL
DURING THAT KICKBALL GAME,
RIGHT? YOU KEEP YEAH. YEAH,
THEY TOLD US A PACK FOR SEVEN
TO TEN DAYS AND THEN THEY'LL
BE LAUNDRY BEING ABLE TO DO
SO AND WE LITERALLY WE GOT
HERE LAST SATURDAY. SO
TODAY'S MONDAY, SO I PACKED
FOR RIGHT AROUND THAT NUMBER.
SO IT'S IT'S GOOD NOW
TO TO GET A EVERYTHING'S
FRESH AND CLEAN. HERE WE GO
AND START RIGHT BACK. OH, I
LOVE IT. I LOVE IT. YOU'RE
PLAYING WITH HOUSE MONEY
RIGHT NOW PAUL. OBVIOUSLY, DO
YOU ALLOW A I PROMISE YOU WE
THINK THAT WAY
DO YOU ALLOW YOURSELF TO LOOK
AHEAD AT ALL TO WHAT COULD BE
NEXT IF YOU ADVANCE
TO BAYLOR VILLANOVA? YEP,
ONLY KNOW THAT BECAUSE I
TALKED TO SCOTT DREW THIS
MORNING AND HE'S LIKE, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE ON THE SAME SIZE
RIGHT? I HAD NO IDEA.
DIDN'T KNOW WHO WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO PLAY AFTER THIS
NOTHING. WHO ARE WE PLAYING
NEXT? AND THEY WERE THE TEXAS
TECH ARKANSAS WINNER AND I
WAS LIKE, OKAY, BUT
HONEST TO GOODNESS. I HAD NO
IDEA. I DID VAGUELY KNOW THAT
THAT FAILURE WAS IN THE SOUTH
BUT IT'S NOT ANYTHING THAT
YOU EVER PAID ATTENTION TO SO
BUT NO WE I CAN ASSURE YOU ALL
OUR ATTENTION. WHAT WILL BE
ON ARKANSAS THIS IS GOING TO
CHANGE THE LIFE OF EVERYBODY
INVOLVED WITH WITH ORAL
ROBERTS BASKETBALL PROGRAM,
BUT PERHAPS NOBODY MORE THAN
YOU DOWN THE ROAD. IS THAT
AND WHAT CONTEXT THERE'S JUST
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES DOORS
OPEN WHEN YOU GUYS DO WHAT
YOU'VE DONE AND THE INFIELD
THE LAST COACH TO DO THAT A
FLORIDA GULF COAST IS YOU
KNOW IS NOW AT USC JUST IN
GENERAL WAY. IT IS GONNA BE
BOOK DEALS. IT COULD BE
ANYTHING. THIS IS A BIG BIG
DEAL IS THAT IT'S SOMETHING
WHEN AS YOU'RE SITTING AROUND
AND YOU'RE DOING YOUR LAUNDRY
THAT YOU ALLOWED TO CREEP
INTO YOUR HEAD. WELL, I WILL
SAY THIS MY ONLY DESIRE EVER
I LOVE THE MOVIE HOOSIERS
RIGHT? I'VE SEEN IT WELL OVER
THOUSAND TIMES.
AND ALL I WANTED TO DO IS BE
A REALLY GOOD HIGH SCHOOL
COACH BECAUSE I JUST LOVE THE
HIGH SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT. I
LOVE THAT INVESTMENT WHAT I
REALIZED IN MY SIX YEARS OF
COACHING HIGH SCHOOL WAS MAN
THESE GUYS NOT THAT YOU
EXPECT THEM TO LOVE IT AS
MUCH AS YOU BUT I'D HAVE ONE
OR TWO GUYS WHO LOVED IT AS
MUCH AS ME SO WHEN I WENT TO
COLLEGE I WAS LIKE, ALL RIGHT,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE AROUND
GUYS WHO ENJOY IT AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M
ABLE TO DO.
DO AND SO FROM THAT CONTEXT.
I MEAN I'M DOING EXACTLY WHAT
I'M CALLED TO DO AND THAT IS
INVESTING IN THE LIVES OF
THESE 18 TO 22 YEAR OLDS AT A
PLACE THAT I BELIEVE IN IN
THE MISSION OF OF INVESTING
IN YOUNG MEN AND AND CAN DO
IT IN A WAY. AND SO I MEAN I
WAKE UP EVERY SINGLE DAY
EXCITED NOT ONLY TO RECRUIT
FOR A WAR YOUTH BUT
YOU INVEST IN OUR PLAYERS
HERE. SO I'M GLAD THAT OUR
PLAYERS GET THIS EXPERIENCE
AND AND I HOPE IT'S EVEN
MORE. I MEAN WHEN I TOOK THE
JOB HONEST-TO-GOODNESS I
TALKED ABOUT BEING IN FINAL
FORCE AND YOU'VE SEEN IT WITH
GONZAGA YOU SING IT WITH
BUTLER AND SEEN IT WITH
LOYOLA CHICAGO SEEN IT WITH
GEORGE MASON. YOU SEE ANY
WITH VISA YOU SEEN IT WITH
WICHITA STATE YOU'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF MID-MAJORS DO THAT.
AND I THINK THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT MAKE COLLEGE
BASKETBALL, SO EXCITING AND
HONESTLY,
BELIEVE WE CAN DO IT HERE AT
ORU AND WHY NOT ORAL ROBERTS.
A RUN IT HAS BEEN SO FAR. HEY
COACH. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE TIME. WE KEPT YOU A
LITTLE LONGER THAN I EXPECTED
THE ENTIRE NATION ALL 49
STATES BESIDES ARKANSAS, I
THINK OF ROOTING FOR YOU GUYS.
SO WELL GOOD LINKS DAY AND
GOOD LUCK COMING UP AGAIN.
APPRECIATE THE TIME. GLAD
YOU'RE GETTING SOME CLEAN
LAUNDRY. AND PLEASE BE
CAREFUL DO NOT PULL A
HAMSTRING IN THAT KICKBALL
GAME THE YOUNG GRAD
ASSISTANTS. YEAH. SO IF I'M
LIMPING ON SATURDAY NIGHT,
YOU'RE THE MAN. GOOD LUCK
COACH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT'S PAUL MILLS FROM ORAL
ROBERTS UNIVERSITY GETTING
READY TO PLAY ARKANSAS COMING
UP HERE IN A FEW DAYS OF 15.
SEE JUST THE SECOND-EVER IN
THE SWEET 16.